bismillah alhamdulillah peace be with
you thank you for tuning in to the Deen
show now I'm telling you to pit all the
inane things to the side just for a
moment get a lot of people who are just
flickering through say oh I saw you on
the TV and I started watching the show
at Hum Dil ah you did you did it again
you were flickering and you tuned in to
the Dean show maybe by accident on
purpose whatever it is don't - now
because we have a former R&B artist who
changed his life for the better he put
all of that stuff to the side the drugs
and the music and the partying and the
nightclubs all of those inane things
that don't bring benefit to the human
soul and he did the most wonderful thing
that a person can do we're gonna be
right back to hear his story here on the
D show he was following the likes of
Justin visit Justin Bieber or Timberlake
are sure you know these guys he's gonna
we're gonna be talking about all this
and more here in the D show you don't
wanna go nowhere be right back
this is the backyard is Easter oh my
Issa peace be with you sound like a
mother how are you hundun
thank you for frying it all the way from
UK indeed how was the trip 111 Hyundai
hamdulillah people heard me mention I
sure got their attention Justin Beaver
got their tour was it Justin Timberlake
because you were R&B singer right you
were trying to be like the likes of them
these are like the most popular icons
out there and you left all that tell us
a little bit about yourself brother
first I signed the name of allah
subhanho wa taala the most just the most
kind the most compassionate the most
merciful the Lord the Honorable throne
the Lord of the al-amin the king of
kings the master Majesty of the heavens
the earth and the universe and I said my
peace and blessings on the beloved
prophet muhammad sallallahoalyhiwasallam
I was from that world where you know
where it was all about the fame the
money and all this kind of stuff and a
lustful thought guided me in 2011 but I
was in the thick of it you know
performing nightclubs doing this
stressing is my son gonna be you know
working in England there's a system we
have just like in the US where you have
to come from the underground you have to
work from the underground I was doing
all of that my manager was a renowned
manager and I was doing all of that but
La Scala saved me now look I always
because you know the Muslims those who
are submitted to the will of God that's
what a Muslim is Jesus was a Muslim
Allah Abraham all the processes that the
Creator sent were Muslim now you started
off you know saying an Arabic word Allah
we got to do this because a lot of our
channels on a station that catches a lot
of not yet Muslims tuned in okay so you
heard you said the word Allah define
what does this mean it's got basically
the one you know true God one and only
God Ya Allah
sounding it is basically how the
Christians would say God we say Allah it
Arabic people who read the Arabic Bible
I love to mention is because the word
for people if they think this is some
foreign God Allah has mentioned in the
Arabic Bible on the first page over a
half a dozen times
subhanAllah so there's not some foreign
got a law of the creator and Aramaic
jesus said aloha and your name is omar
Issa and an Arabic look that means Jesus
your last name is Jesus and we love
Jesus we don't worship Him but how does
this your last name is Jesus ISA Jesus
yeah he's you know he's a beloved
prophet of our religion Islam and you
know as you said we love Him you know
and it's my wish in short life Allah
smart Allah blessed me with a child I'm
gonna call him Issa as well we shot a
lot I mean this is so farcical laughable
when people start to make Muslims out
like the Antichrist when it's a pillar
of our religion to believe in Christ
Jesus peace be upon him we strongly
object to people saying that he was God
a literal son of God right we believe he
was a mighty Messenger of God like
Abraham Moses you know so it's laughable
but you got even someone you're gonna
name your child after Jesus that's
amazing and shall I God willing so tell
us a little bit more you live in this
life fast life and you told me something
when we were talking a little bit that
you were you were actually in between
both worlds a little bit you were still
holding out a little bit to the Salah
the prayer
yeah right but you'd make it into what
you make Jamaat in a nightclub how'd
that work out I used to basically I've
always had fear of Allah that's one
thing I've always had my mom always put
that in me and ever since I was 16 I was
praying sulabha I had dreams big dreams
of becoming this superstar you know and
the weird thing about me was I used to
perform in a nightclub and he's to come
home and still pretty sure and I say my
mind pray to Allah Allah you know take
me to the Grammys take me to all these
MTV Awards make me the star that I want
to be and it was weird it was weird but
Allah spinal doll was always with me you
know always there you know you'd said
she put the fear of God in you yeah you
know many people they have this false
notion that God you know the the Muslim
law the crater the crater of them our
maker their maker just as God would you
just fear him but you know in the Bible
I just want to mention in proverbs says
in Psalms the beginning the fearing God
is the beginning of wisdom
right so but what's the balance we know
that there's a balance people
and fear you know dude did you just fear
God or did you love him also know
everything before we start with anything
we say bismillah ar-rahman ar-rahim we
start in the name of Allah the most
compassionate the most merciful
you know so doesn't that say in itself
everything apart from one surah in the
noble quran and islamic holy book
we always start by saying that in the
name of all of the most compassionate
the most merciful so that says it all a
lhasa
mercy / overcomes his wrath he's the
most loving it what dude he's the most
loving it yes I mean no but don't take
like the second command don't take God's
name in vain right so now you're gonna
be to all his love love love and then
you're just you know doing all these
horrific acts you got to fear God - yeah
if cool down with love it's a balance
yeah of course
beautiful so now how did you get out of
this rut I mean because we know we're
not supposed to be in places that don't
help us to become the best human beings
my clubs obviously where you know
adultery is occurring fornication drugs
alcohol bad things evil things how did
you end up getting out of this bad
environment and becoming a better human
being
it was old from when I was as I said
when I was young this thing that my mom
put in me you know I'm born a Muslim but
you know I can't say I was a practicing
Muslim so when I knew inside it wasn't
feeling right every time I was going
into the studio I was thinking what am i
doing Allah so Allah has put me on this
earth to do something for my Dean just
to try to use what Allah and Allah has
given me and Mytyl Esperanto has given
me a voice alhamdulillah and I thought
what am I gonna do what am I gonna what
can I do for my Dean so slowly slowly it
started changing inside of me did you
taste okay because they wiii say look
when you taste this Deen this way of
life from the crater and then you tasted
some of the dunya did it taste different
of course of course the sweetness of you
know falling you know falling in love
with Islam is something I can't expect
no love will ever match that no husband
and wife no football team no baseball
team nothing is the true love is only
with Allah and that came in me and they
happen 2011 I remember the day clearly
when I stopped Dana
now tell us because there's your from UK
yes and there was some events that
happened in UK and now someone who's
watching and not yet Muslims they're
like okay
all of this stuff sounds good but we
know we just know you know what's really
going down you guys are like you know
execute people in the middle of the
street over there and UK what do you
feel when you see your your religion
this way of life from the crater
you know betrayed in this negative way
in the wrong way like this how do you
feel I feel I'm frustrated that's what
we all Muslims because they won't show
people like us you know we're
law-abiding citizens you know we're
we're British Muslims you know we love
the country but we love our Deen first
and and the thing is that there's knife
crimes happening every day in London I
come from a very violent city you know
and it's happening all the time so we
have to look at that this is because the
guy said Allahu Akbar and he recited a
few ayahs from the noble quran all of a
sudden he's a practicing Muslim you know
we have to look at the backstory look at
who they are to me they were just there
were just normal guys they were
murderers there weren't Muslims I hadn't
attacked them they weren't Christians
they weren't Jews they weren't Muslims
to me you know to do that
you know Allah Allah Allah knows best
but all I'm saying is that happens all
the time in London you know there's
nothing you can't malign a whole way of
life you know that's that's been there I
mean since the first man Adam Islam has
been their submission to the will of God
you got now Muhammad peace be upon him
many people have this notion that
Mohammed it's a new religion but Islam
has been there since Jesus's time Moses
time cement that concept was submitting
yourself to the creator and now we have
it in its pristine form we have the
verbatim Word of God the Quran and
nowhere does the instruction manual of
how we need to live you know from A to Z
give us the command to go and kill
innocent men women children in the city
you know blowing up people
indiscriminately I mean have you found
that in fact in the noble quran allah so
allah says when you kill one man it's
like you kill whole of humanity and if
you save one man it's like you've saved
all of humanity so what does that say
yeah a lot what Allah the the king of
kings
the Lord of the universe is saying so
you know human beings never ever look at
a Muslim to find out about Islam always
go to Islam go find out by killing
innocent people is wrong is wrong you
can't obviously in a just war you have a
right to defend yourself course your
property your home and that but ok so I
like what you said knife crimes happen I
know you know here every so many seconds
there's a person being assaulted
you know there's violent crimes
happening murder every few minutes a
woman's being you know raped every 90
seconds or so and you don't you know
look at the person's religion right it's
the same thing I'm sure UK happening all
these violent crimes always happening
you know it's exactly the same any city
you're gonna go to anywhere in fact in
the world the world is changing so
drastically that it's always happening
you cannot blame a religion you know and
there's so many there's much Suhana
London Lee two billion of us you know if
we were that bad the world would be
really really bad you know if you look
at like that it's just you know
sometimes the media you know it's
basically that as they say some you know
what's the flavor of the month and
Islam's have been the flavor of the
month for a while now it's it's been
absolutely what you said and I mean
that's like you see the statistics of
people who are intelligent academics
Christian scholars who are coming to
Islam seeing the contradictions in the
man-made religions who are accepting
Islam and the peacemakers have been made
to look like the war mongers that's the
sad part because Islam is promoting
peace yeah peace with to create a peace
within yourself and peaceful society so
when when you sit and you learn Islam
you see you know the beautiful teachings
yeah this is this is so absurd yeah it's
very sad it's very sad when you say
you're right the finally the Allah Allah
Allah is the greatest of planners
whenever this happens more people come
to Islam so really they can plan like
Allah so Allah says in the Quran they
can plan your I plan but I'm the
greatest of planners that's why it
behooves you to pick up this car and the
verbatim word of God to study the life
of the last and final messenger now
scented to Arab or just to the Pakistani
he sent to the American and a whole of
mankind if you in UK Britain he is sent
as a mercy to the world study his life
in context ask the Creator the gaijin
you'll see that he was as the crater
described him he was sent as a mercy to
the world that's right we'll be right
back
got more time all right we'll be right
back with more here in the Dean show
growing up in America
Eddie lived the American dream he
achieved it all before the age of thirty
money cars but beneath the surface
something didn't feel after achieving
everything he ever designed and he
turned his back and walked away from it
all and took his life in a whole new
direction let us take you on his journey
back here on the D show where Omar Issa
left this life or the imitation of
people who are not helping to produce
good human beings because I mean how can
you like imitating Lady Gaga Lady Gugu
or uh sure or you know what's that the
Justin Beaver's I mean really if you
look at many of these people's lives all
of their lives they're either in rehab
you look at dr. drew you know they do
celebrity rehabs these people's lives
are upside down so you were heading in
that direction
you left it yeah so what are you doing
with your time with yourself now
basically I've used what a lot smaller
God has given me my voice and I'm I do
the sheets they see Islamic form of
putting the message out there using the
voice I just use my voice that's what I
do I don't use no instruments you know
back in the day used to be all about the
guitars the drums everything now it's
just my voice and the voice is the most
powerful tool we have so I'm using it
for the sake of a less violent I love
spreading my salam through my melodies
you know I say I give it actually attack
actually I say I came from R&B now it's
a and B Islam and blue tell us now look
you want BBC yeah you've been on some
other famous radio stations or
television stations yeah you on the BBC
lately just recently just before I came
to the US I was in tell us a story yeah
I was on it was an amazing amazing
experience I was on a program that's
called the big question it comes on
every Sundays a live debate show
and they always debate about things that
are happening and on this particular
show they were debating the topic about
Syria actually and another topic and
about music and religion and this host
himself whenever I've watched the show
anyway he's very anti Islam very are you
sure it's the Word of God so what was
who is Mohamed Salah well he was salam i
usually didn't do that and what happened
was them he came to me and he said to me
you know what is your opinion on what
you trying to do through and i wouldn't
look my message is to come and talk
about my Islam in the way that the media
will not show about the way that how my
Prophet Muhammad said lowly was selling
was the greatest human being to walk to
face the earth and then some time there
was a beautiful a moment that he goes
can you sing can you do something and I
did I sang him and a she'd of mine with
him basically I recite let us hear what
so he asked you to go ahead and recite
one of the songs yeah but which one did
you do basically I just went um how
perfect my allies and I praise he subhan
allahi wa bihamdihi subhanAllah hey lady
I said that and he said well he said
I'll just touch me so I came from I
actually said to I in the hadith the
promoter Louis Lama said that these are
the most beloved words to allah subhan
allahi wa bihamdihi subhana allah deem
how perfect allah is and i praise him
and he tweeted me three times you you
know or Maresa you really touched me you
you tweeted you know yeah he tweeted me
it's three i'm gonna swear i screen
saved him because he's known for his you
know and you know what he said he's
quite aggressive towards the sam sir it
was a blessing from allah for me to put
that all the audience for clapping him
before that they were sniggering when
another brother was talking about islam
and this they were like yeah right yeah
i like they did yeah and then they went
quiet
you know and the christian lady was
sitting next to me and she when you know
your voice is beautiful
there was a christian guy next me a
rapper they were like you should do
something together to put the message
out there was a beautiful - beautiful
moment i mean obviously we don't we
don't compromise when it comes to this
way of life that's from the creator you
know we speak the truth yeah in a polite
way we try not to disparage you against
anyone you know when we talk about jesus
being a mighty messenger we never
disrespect him and when we talked even
people like that the creator tells us in
the Quran you know to fight evil with
goodness yes right yes so I mean we want
to give some advice to the brothers also
who are out there who are following
sooner the way of the Prophet but when
you come with this harshness you know
when they'll and they'll take a snapshot
of this a video and then they're arguing
with the hose and they're getting
belligerent and you know represented in
a Dean well the Prophet peace be upon
him ever did that stuff no not just so
you know the thing is that that show
taught me something and it taught me
that what I'm doing indeed Allah Allah
Tala is I'm on the correct way of doing
it in my way I'm coming through him from
a melody point of view they're gonna
listen
one of minor sheets is called Mohammed
solo elusive it's about the revelation
of the noble Qur'an it's the story you
know how he went the Haditha that the
allah and his wife his beautiful wife
and he was talking about and when they
listen to these stories the amount of
christian people i've had who have come
to me and said one person actually said
to me came back to me and said after
listening to your album i played it to
three christians and they said tell your
friend we didn't know Islam was a
religion of peace and I went hungry luck
alhamdulillah our sness now no you know
you're not gonna soften the hearts we
really recommend you're from UK and you
got are you are there I always say you
have a humdinger abdul rahim green you
know what are the other homs resources
give what's the other brother also all
of the brothers there you know our fat
fabulous brothers and i really encourage
the brothers from UK you know they did a
event or they put together program and
they went to the Olympics was it
Olympics yeah they were giving dowel out
there writing people to the purpose of
life be a farm and so many people are
coming to this way of life is the
fastest going way of like that's our I
really encourage people to go they have
a program how to give dowel they have
yeah they have a dollar thing they're
doing it's you just go go to our website
yeah and it's everything there they do
it they're doing it I think they
spreading out now learn how to do it the
right way not the wrong way because you
end up scaring people away with your
France mile a little bit more and invite
people to this beautiful way of life so
tell us now have you had challenges in
your life and how have you overcome them
because you know the desire and man is
strong right so usually the desire you
know it drives someone to the nightclubs
it drives someone to chase that manner
then what the woman's looking for the
attention for man and she gets used by
man right God tells us to do it in the
right way through marriage have the
family of all and and the blueprint is
laid out there yeah so now obviously
sometimes
have that hard time to submit Islam
means peacefully submitting to the
creator has it been a challenge it's
been a challenge you know I'm a West as
I Sarah I'm like I'm a guy from the West
and it's very difficult you know you see
all the time the peer pressure you see
people have I've got I've got this
girlfriend and I've got this up you know
I going to this club I'm listening to
this track this new thing and you have
to understand that this world is very
very temporary you know the real real
you know you sometimes in this life you
feel empty very empty you see a lot of
times people have got money got
everything they're empty
just recently two years ago Amy
Winehouse one of the biggest singers in
the world killed herself you know she
drunk herself said she drank herself to
death what was her name
Amy Winehouse Amy why she was a big
famous celebrity amazing voice indeed a
lot smarter I did bless her with that
voice and she just drunk herself to
death literally and when you see that
you think you know what indeed heaven is
a place where we're gonna have true
happiness and that's what I'm fighting
for
that's why I walked the streets and I
lower my gaze that's why I talk to
people in a respectful way that's why I
do not answer back when I when someone
does road rage to me
because I think how allah subhanho wa
taala the master my lord my judge count
me on that what will he say to me on the
day of your glamour because we are all
going to be accounted for everything we
do good and bad have you felt because we
know it's an incumbent on every Muslim
when I was who has submitted to the will
of the creator
Jesus was a must always remind people
there's not a foreign way of lightness
from the crater yeah you know Abraham
was not a Jew or Christian but he was
one who submitted to the rule of God he
was a Muslim that's what a Muslim is so
now a Muslim is commanded to pray five
times a day now because God needs is
because our medicine we need it right so
has this really helped you as God has
said in the crown a law that you know
established a prayer because it keeps
one away from evil shameless deeds you
know how do you feel that that's like
and for the people aren't praying
motivating them to start with the Salah
it's the the best thing every time
something's happened to me when I turn
to Allah and I turn to Salah prayer it
helps me you know it's the sweetness of
when you listen to the words and what
you're assigned you know it's a you know
in every every Salah prayer that we do
we have to recite surah fatiha the first
surah of the Quran and basically when
we're talking about it we're we're
saying Allah sponsor of this Allah so
Allah says the first part is my servant
is praising me and the second prize for
him
and indeed whenever I've gone through
hardship a loss panel hotel has never
ever let me down so lies the only way
you know it's the only way you've where
I find my piece anyway yeah now we want
to distinguish between judging someone
judging will be for the crater on the
day of judging it a law will judge
everybody now we want to give the sweet
advice because that's what we're
commanded to do you know and you have a
lot of the people out there who they
turn for solace they turn to the bottle
yeah they turn to music it's addictive
wake up to it it's numbing to mine all
the entertainment instead of running
towards the crater and asking for
forgettings or the one who is supposed
to be a Muslim he's running towards uh
sure wakes up to it when he's got a
problem just blasts the radio and that's
all he's doing you know to find that
comfort and for a minute it just takes
all his problems but for a minute but
then the bigger side if it comes yeah
haha what kind of ice do you get for
those people I honestly I was there you
know they said I was there I was I was
that guy who used to anything there was
a problem I said listen to a song and I
used to sleep sometimes listen to music
and I used to wake up singing that song
not not saying la la hey la la no saying
you know a lot smaller I was the only
got the one true God but singing these
songs and my wrist answer to that was
now I try my best to listen to the Quran
then words are something else they touch
you and like you said brother we can't
judge people you know we don't know who
is beloved to Allah there might be a
person out there who doesn't pray Salah
but he's more beloved to Allah than the
person who prays five times a day
it's about what your heart is who you
are as a human being if you're good to
human beings and you treat everybody
fairly and you don't want anything back
from anybody you just want it back from
Allah you are indeed the most successful
and that's how I try to live my life cuz
you've been there you tasted that again
never helped me they never helped you so
but now connecting with Allah the
Creator the maker through the verbatim
word of God has this helped you always
helps me always help me every time I
feel when I perform I have a really
adrenaline rush and I try to calm myself
and I turned the Quran on and it brings
me a lot of ease and it brings me back
down to earth brings me back down to say
that you know I'm just a servant of
Allah and I'm just putting a message out
there yeah and you can't expect now just
all at once you know you're turning to
the court you got to give you so you got
to sincerely
yourself to the creator for it to work
Allah ask I ask Allah I sent to Allah
you know I've known lots of brothers
because mashallah is a big Muslim
community in England and brothers have
said I all I did was ask
I said please Allah guide be like a
beggar yes please cuz if we need some
food or money we put our hands out like
this right in the prophets didn't pray
like this they pray like this like bit
like we need some oh Allah the Creator
give it to me yes right
yeah and that's how you get it you have
to plead you have to ask yes of course
so let's start with that start right now
you can start right now no matter what
condition you're in
ask the Creator the maker to guide you
to help you with any of your problems
and he'll do that guaranteed if you're
sincere we'll be right back with more
here in the D show
back here on the Dean show where Omar
Issa we talked about your last name
actually being the name of Jesus Issa
and Arabic Jesus in English no Muslim is
a Muslim unless he believes in Jesus is
one of the mightiest messengers as God
we got a lot of not yet Muslims out
there but at the end of the show they
might even accept his way of life from
the crater Islam submission to the will
of God so tell us now Omar I saw you in
your Nasheed's you use only the voice
yes right
have you had some people objected say
come on man throw in the guitar in the
base brother all the time all the time I
say to him you know I've been there done
that and let me tell you something
you know I'm what I'm getting now the
fulfillment I'm feeling now that I'm
putting it out then I'm speaking about
my Allah and my prophet muhammad's Aloha
so I'm a beautiful religion Islam
there's no better feeling so I'm not
gonna go there
why would I want to do that I can go
back to the R&B world really that's
where they're really yeah you know
that's where the money is if you think
about if you go there and then the sheet
game is there's not this it's if you're
doing it you have to be sincere for the
sake of Allah do it for a pure intention
when you're doing RMB my intention was
all about the money all about the fame
all about being noticed on the street
all that sir keeping the intention
purely for the crater yeah so important
we have to do that run by myself and all
those watching that our intentions have
to be right and they'll all help us to
purify intentions I mean so now have you
had a chance in trying to talk with
people you know because it's it's an
obligation every Muslim to share if we
care we share should we share the
purpose of life you know with humanity
and three through your vocals have you
had a chance to talk to someone and not
yet Muslims and and use you mentioned
the BBC yeah and it touched someone have
yet other experiences like this yeah
there's been loads as with me it's
whenever I push and the sheet out and
I've got three machines out at the
moment and an album was born whenever I
put that stuff out
people always write messages saying
stuff like I don't know what you're
talking about I don't know about your
religion but if something's touched me
inside and then I write to them I'm like
you know what I'm here for you any
question you want out and you know a
dialogue begins yeah a dialogue because
when you start talking about and you
start speaking about and at the end of
the day
when you when when I speak to somebody
at the only Allah is the one who guides
so I can give them that plant the seed
is always a beautiful thing to do and
then in shot la May of last month I let
it flourish that's it that's it it's our
duty just to convey
we can't force nobody but it's
everyone's God give it right that they
should know what Islam is yeah tell us
now look let's go back
well let's translate some of those words
right the ones that you use song so
eloquently beautifully to that
interviewer yeah you said say I said
subhan allahi wa bihamdihi subhanAllah
Elodie how perfect Allah is let's stop
right there how perfect the crater is
this and you can take off with the pure
monotheism from that that he's not a man
he's not a woman he doesn't sleep
because if he's perfect absolute he
doesn't need any of the things that
human beings need doesn't need food he
doesn't need air he doesn't need water
he's perfect yes so go ahead continue
and I praise Him only you know I praise
Him only I'm lost Valentine's the praise
boy he's worthy of all praise I could
say thank you brother for being on a
Deen show but he's worthy of all praise
because he gave us the eyes that we see
with yes that the ears that we hear with
the heart that we love what he gave us
that so he's worthy of all praise the
Creator the Creator and keep going
that's what I did I just recited that
day and I just then I said in English so
I translate so he heard it in Arabic and
English I touched him in both that goes
back to to the toe he'd yes the pure
monotheism that all the messengers
brought and taught yeah amazing amazing
I just get really excited a hamdulillah
we're almost coming to an end
tell us about your future plans now your
future projects that you have that
you're working on I just stare recently
in November released my album my first
album
I've only been doing nasheed since June
2011 and I just released and I've
actually got a little present for you
brother here's an album to meet you
thank you and I'm doing them as a voice
campaign we're doing at the moment where
we're just a baby
we need a substitute I'm telling you we
need to substitute people need to get
rid of all the punk rock yeah and the
hip hop and all the stuffs like get
their money get that hole get that dough
yo yo yo we have to get rid of that
stuff because that's contaminating our
mind yeah
and it puts us in a false reality it
takes us into a dreamland the fantasy I
was there too I look I've been there
done that I was into an entertainment
world and you just wake up to it go to
sleep to it put put it in your ride you
got the kit you know the kicker's in the
back and you boom boom you need just
numb in your mind yeah right but you
know so we if we say something's head-on
we take it away with something replace
it with something better that's not what
the with - she that I tried to do a
story with every machine there's one
mushy that actually did with a brother
of the laro it's called the promise of
Allah and in that machine I'm talking
about an eye in the Quran where Allah
says verily with hardship there is
relief so you know people are you see
all over the world people are feeling
down people are depressed if his work if
his wife if his children you see and you
think to yourself you know
indeed if you turn to Allah you will get
your ease because that's the only I'm a
witness to it you know I can't express
it enough and that's what I'm trying to
do I'm doing a voice campaign at the
moment where I'm just doing basically
what I'm trying to say to people is
anything music can do so can the voice
inshallah and so you work with you also
what have you guys thought about doing a
joint effort again I had them on the
show I love the book Abdullah roll yeah
Salaam alaikum peace be with you we're
gonna have you back you could check him
out - there's none greater than the
Creator you know this one I know not to
sing I know I know there's none greater
than the Creator that's the song
Abdullah Road that's right and then we
got Omar Issa get their stuff get their
stuff the good stuff stay away from all
this the stuff that's not doing you any
good now so we almost got to go we got
like they're saying one minute can you
can you sing something of course I'm
this year I'm going to do is called the
one it's about the oneness of Allah so
abysmal Larimer him I'm so tired
feels like a walked a thousand miles
uninspired done yes got me on my knees
but thankfully I've got Islam oh it gets
me through trying times
oh and when I read the noble Qur'an oh
it tells me what's the
and give me all the proof my Allah is
the one the one the one one the one the
one the one the one my ladies though uh
took me too long but God is great thank
you so much that was really inspiring
Hum Dil ah thank you my baby Bella's
thank you thank you very much
I love word you thank you so much no no
hum did a lie and that was omar Issa we
want to replace the bad with the good
there ain't nothing like the book that
was sent to mankind the verbatim would
have got the Quran connect with that and
if you need some entertainment in your
life do it the right way not the wrong
way so get this CD also I'll do a roll
and you got Omar Esau hook up with these
brothers and you know the beautiful
thing is that all of us go through
hardships but when you got like the
brother was singing you know about the
perfect one the Creator who is there for
us you just have to reach out to him
and he's there Allah the Creator you
don't even have to say Allah say my
maker the one who made me the one who
Jesus prayed to he said our Father who
art in heaven hallowed be thy name thy
kingdom mourn thy will be done so that's
the one the Lord's Prayer right there
if you're a Christian Jew there's no one
there where it says like and in the name
of Jesus there's no just the Creator
don't who Jesus Jesus he prostrate to
his to the ground and he prayed to God
beseech God's help ask him for
forgiveness and he'll facilitate away
and and try to reach for something
that's higher than the Stars
because you wouldn't as I had a guest
before he and he saw he was like you
wouldn't trade a Bentley for a bike or
airplane for a kite why trade Jenna
paradise for this dunya you know you're
gonna die and at the end the day of
judgment and Hellfire paradise so that
we work to please our Creator before we
meet our Creator start today no matter
what bad or evil things you've done he's
the most loving the most merciful start
to ask him for help and guidance the one
create tour
and continue to visit us here on the
Dean show you can call us also 106 6-2
Islam to pick up the verbatim word I've
got it behooves you to read this book
you read it every other book read this
book read this book and find out for
yourself if it's the truth and we'll see
you next time God willing until then
peace be with you